y
[Música]
a 5 meses de los juegos olímpicos de
tokio el presidente del comité
organizador yoshiro mori renunció este
viernes a su cargo tras la polémica
desatada por unos comentarios sexistas
el comité olímpico internacional aseguró
que está tan comprometido como siempre a
trabajar con su sucesor
en la tercera jornada del histórico
segundo impeachment contra el ex
presidente de donald trump
los fiscales demócratas concluyeron en
sus alegatos que se trompas absuelto
podría volver a incitar a la violencia
hoy el turno es para los abogados del
exmandatario
sigue sin conocerse oficialmente quién
será el contrincante de andrés hará uso
en la segunda vuelta a las
presidenciales de ecuador con el 99 96
por ciento de las actas procesadas el
candidato indígena ya q pérez es tercero
y se reunirá en las próximas horas con
el centroderechista guillermo lazo que
está en segundo lugar
gracias por continuar con nosotros en
france 24 soy valentina torre sánchez
iniciamos esta misión en japón porque
tras una polémica sexista renunció el
hasta hoy presidente del comité
organizador de los juegos olímpicos de
tokio george ir o morir los comentarios
del funcionario provocar un rechazo
internacional en su más reciente
comparecencia ante la prensa se disculpó
y aseguró que no sabía si sus palabras
habían molestado a las mujeres porque no
habla mucho con ellas veamos más
detalles en el informe de mar romera
faltan cinco meses para los juegos
olímpicos de tokio y el evento deportivo
se quedó sin presidente yoshiro mori
quien lideraba el proyecto de las
olimpiadas dimitió en medio de una
oleada de críticas por unos comentarios
sexistas que dijo durante una reunión
efectivamente a partir de hoy dimito
como presidente lo importante es que las
olimpiadas sucedan en julio y no puedo
permitir que mi presencia complique las
preparaciones
político quinto
morir se quejó de las reuniones donde
hay muchas mujeres argumentando que
duran más tiempo porque hablan demasiado
el propio comité olímpico de tokio tiene
cinco mujeres entre sus 24 integrantes
estas declaraciones levantaron polémica
las mismas autoridades japonesas
criticaron con dureza amor y quien
inicialmente solo se disculpó pero no
renunció a su cargo
con la presión japonesa internacional y
también de la opinión pública el
presidente decidió dar un paso al lado
creo que la renuncia es lo correcto era
vergonzoso para japonés algo bueno
morí ex primer ministro de 83 años deja
los juegos en un momento delicado casi
la mitad de los japoneses opinan que el
evento debería volver a posponerse por
la pandemia además no hay un sucesor
claro para hacerse cargo del liderazgo
de las olimpiadas unas olimpiadas que no
dejan de encontrar tropiezos por el
camino continuamos en eeuu en la tercera
jornada del impeachment contra el ex
presidente de donald trump
los fiscales demócratas concluyeron su
alegato asegurando que si trump no es
condenado podría incitar a nuevos hechos
violentos e incluso inspirar a otros
funcionarios en el futuro asimismo
resaltaron que el ex mandatario sabía
exactamente lo que estaba haciendo
cuando convocó a sus partidarios a
luchar hasta las últimas consecuencias
previamente hablamos con nuestro
corresponsal cristóbal vázquez quien ha
vivido estas jornadas de juicio político
al interior del capitolio y nos contó
sobre las reacciones que han tenido los
republicanos tras el alegato de los
fiscales demócratas
ayer atrás tras conocerse las las
contundentes pruebas los vídeos y los
testimonios que entregaron los
demócratas que mostraban como donald
trump sabía de estos ataques antes de
que ocurrieran como incitó esta
violencia el 6 de enero y como no hizo
nada al respecto el senador richard
blumenthal se preguntaba que si el voto
fuese secreto los republicanos en
realidad si terminarían absorbiendo a
donald trump
y es que tras presentar estos vídeos
muchos republicanos que estaban en
plenaria se mostraron afectados
afectados de ver como efectivamente las
palabras de donald trump terminaron
incitando a la violencia pero lo que
están diciendo muchos analistas es que a
pesar de haberse visto afectados los
republicanos lo votarán en contra de
primero porque no se van a arriesgar a
perder el apoyo los votos de sus
simpatizantes en los estados que
representan y por ende pues arriesgar la
reelección en el senado y segundo porque
si votan en contra de donald trump le
dejaría en el camino libre el argumento
dado para que donald trump
pues cree este tercer político el
partido patriota que dice que podría
crear en caso de tener en la falta de
apoyo por parte de los republicanos a
las 12 del mediodía de hoy hora de
washington continúa el juicio político y
el turno es para la defensa del ex
presidente de donald trump entretanto el
departamento de seguridad nacional
anunció que a partir del 19 de febrero
reabrir a los casos de los solicitantes
de asilo devueltos a méxico por la
política migratoria del expresidente
trump que obligaba a estas personas a
permanecer en ese país a la espera de
sus citas en cortes de inmigración
estadounidenses la nueva medida del
gobierno de joe biden es parte de la
fase en uno de un programa para
restaurar el procesamiento seguro y
ordenado de inmigrantes en la frontera
sur según los datos oficiales se estima
que unas 25.000 personas tienen casos
activos
vamos a ecuador falta un 0,49 para
concluir el escrutinio de las elecciones
presidenciales del domingo pasado y para
saber quién será el contrincante en la
segunda vuelta del candidato del ex
presidente rafael correa andrés araus el
centroderechista guillermo lasso
mantiene una mínima ventaja sobre el
líder indígena ya q pérez que ha
solicitado oficialmente el recuento de
los votos en siete provincias tras
alegar que un supuesto fraude en la
mañana de este viernes lazo y pere se
reunirán en el consejo nacional
electoral
un fraude es caro
y esto lo que está haciendo es
dejando malherida a la democracia
la democracia es hoy una caricatura es
un teatro de mal gusto
una tristeza suprema no le están robando
a ya q pérez los bots
le están robando todo un proyecto todo
un sueño toda una esperanza que tenían
los ecuatorianos en venezuela al inicio
del 2021 un canal digital de noticias
fue cerrado un portal web hackeado y
varios medios de comunicación han sido
estigmatizados de servir para injerencia
extranjera por recibir cooperación
internacional diversos organismos han
solicitado que cesen los ataques a la
libertad de expresión nuestra
corresponsal
herminia fernández nos cuenta desde
caracas
el pasado 8 de enero el canal de
noticias privado bp y cesó sus
operaciones en venezuela luego de que
las autoridades confiscaran sus equipos
y clausurada los estudios esta acción
dejó sin empleo a 45 personas entre
ellos a la periodista antonieta la roca
lo peor que le puede pasar un periodista
es que lo callen que le pongan un tiro
en la boca que le quiten su micrófono
que le pongan dos yeso en cada mano y le
impidan escribir y eso es precisamente
lo que está pasando en venezuela y no
voy ahorita esto data desde hace mucho
tiempo más de 20 años acá en el país el
portal de noticias digital efecto cocuyo
también ha sido blanco de ataque el
propio nicolás maduro le acusa de
recibir dinero de manera ilegal por
parte de instituciones internacionales
para actuar en contra del estado
venezolano para su director a los medios
reyes las autoridades quieren evitar que
los ciudadanos se informen y es además
una deformación una distorsión porque no
están cuestionando el financiamiento
externo sino que además están diciendo
sugiriendo que este financiamiento es
para convertir en informe escenario o
para atacar al gobierno yo creo que es
una de las hipótesis es ir reduciendo
cada día más
las posibilidades de acceso a la
información de los ciudadanos
otra táctica para silenciar los medios
ataques cibernéticos es lo que el
periódico digital tal cual experimentó
durante varios días en el mes de enero
futuro es bastante complicado
muy difícil porque lo que podemos
esperar es un periodismo independiente
que desaparezca en venezuela- que sea
una sola voz la que haya en el país que
sea la voz oficial luego de las últimas
agresiones a los medios de comunicación
en la corte interamericana de derechos
humanos ha exhortado a las autoridades
venezolanas a propiciar un entorno libre
de hostilidades ya respetar las
libertades una sugerencia que se le ha
hecho al gobierno de nicolás maduro sin
obtener resultados
herminia fernández france24 caracas
cambiamos de tema
en octubre de 2017 cataluña celebró un
referendo para separarse de españa sin
embargo la votación nunca fue reconocida
y los líderes independentistas
terminaron en la cárcel o escapando a
bélgica más de tres años después cerca
de seis millones de catalanes vuelven
este 14 de febrero a las urnas para unas
elecciones autonómicas que en un primer
momento fueron suspendidas por la
pandemia pero con wes obligó a celebrar
permitiendo incluso el voto de los
contagiados informa lluís muñoz
independencia o unionismo la eterna
cuestión en cataluña vuelve a las urnas
en un parlamento fraccionado destacan
dos bloques actualmente la comunidad
autónoma está gobernada por dos partidos
independentistas para estos comicios los
sondeos no muestran tendencias claras y
podrían forjarse nuevas fórmulas de
coalición más allá del independentismo
una posibilidad que ha abierto el
socialista salvador y ya quien ha sido
ministro de sanidad del gobierno de
españa' hasta hace unas semanas y que ha
recibido el respaldo del presidente
pedro sánchez el desafío que tienes por
delante durante los próximos meses y los
próximos años sin duda alguna es
apasionante es complejo
pero muy necesario necesario para
cataluña muy necesario también para
españa por su parte los independentistas
confían en volver a gobernar para ello
cuentan con la participación en campaña
de algunos líderes independentistas
encarcelados como el ex vicepresidente
catalán nuria junqueras en libertad
condicional
ahora dormimos todas las noches en la
cárcel
salimos todas las mañanas a caminar por
las calles del país a necesitar al lado
de la gente gusta que bajen los debates
electorales se han centrado una vez más
en la cuestión nacional pero han estado
marcados por la pandemia tras acordar
los partidos un retraso en los comicios
la justicia obligó a celebrar las
elecciones justificando que el sufragio
es un derecho fundamental sondeos prevén
una caída histórica en la participación
mientras que ayuntamientos han tenido
que buscar voluntarios para ocupar las
mesas electorales el voto por correo se
ha triplicado y los colegios electorales
se preparan para que voten incluso los
contagiados
vamos a mí al mar más de 350 personas
entre ellas dirigentes activistas y
monjes han sido detenidas desde el golpe
de estado del primero de febrero así lo
denuncio la oficina de naciones unidas
para los derechos humanos mientras que
continúan las multitudinarias protestas
contra los militares en la última
jornada se registraron nuevos choques
con las autoridades que dispararon balas
de goma al menos tres personas
resultaron heridas
en china del año nuevo lunar que
comienza este viernes es habitualmente
la mayor migración anual del mundo
cientos de millones de trabajadores en
beijing regresan a sus ciudades de
origen sin embargo las autoridades han
desaconsejado los viajes después de que
después de los recientes brotes de
coronavirus en diciembre y enero que
obligaron a generalizar los requisitos
de pruebas pcr y la cuarentena
[Música]
regresar a casa para celebrar el año del
buey a pesar de un viaje repleto de
restricciones contra el cob y 19 o
quedarse solo en beijing como piden las
autoridades
el dilema atormenta a los chinos que
trabajan en la capital
echo mucho de menos mi casa pero por
otro lado tenemos que pensar en todos
así que he decidido no volver esta vez
vientos
el año nuevo lunar que este año que el
12 de febrero es la fiesta más
importante en china y normalmente
cientos de millones de trabajadores
aprovechan la oportunidad para regresar
a sus provincias de origen sin embargo
la alcaldía de la capital pidió este año
a los residentes que evitarán los
desplazamientos innecesarios y no
podemos volver a nuestra ciudad natal
pero paradójicamente en un momento así
la gente parece querer reunirse aún más
en familia y espera valorar mejor el
tiempo que pasen juntos sigan transición
hong kong para evitar que los chinos
viajen beijing ha prometido dedicar 6
millones de dólares en cupones de
descuento para los que se queden en la
capital también ofrece películas en
línea y paquetes de datos móviles para
celulares y está funcionando los viajes
en tren y avión han caído un 80 por
ciento respecto al año pasado
después de superar todo eso espero que
el próximo año podamos vivir y trabajar
con más optimismo por el momento los
viajeros que entren en beijing deben
presentar una prueba pcr
y luego someterse a otras dos pruebas
siete y catorce días después de su
llegada unas medidas que podrían ser
endurecidas al iniciar este año del buey
asociado para los chinos a la
perseverancia y la paciencia finalizamos
con una triste noticia para los amantes
del jazz falleció el legendario pianista
chick korea a los 79 años
el músico que era el cuarto artista con
más nominaciones a los grammy en la
historia murió a causa de un cáncer que
le fue descubierto recientemente en su
último mensaje público pidió a todas las
personas que quieran tocar música
escribir o actuar que se lancen a
hacerlo porque el mundo necesita más
artistas
[Música]
con estas imágenes llegamos al fin del
informativo volvemos en unos momentos
con más esto es france24
[Música]